j'adore cette maison c'est ma maison je
pense que là pour moi c'est la chose la
plus importante de la vie une maison un
endroit où tout se passe quoi d'ailleurs
j'ai jamais envie d'aller en vacances je
vais jamais en vacances pendant les
vacances
être ici avec un qui nous avec mon fils
avec les chiens avec des amis de temps
en temps comme un lien par exemple le
puits de la musique c'est très calme
c'est ici que ça m'est venue l'idée du
sud vous pouvez me raconter un peu ce
sud
c'est cette maison finalement c'est
n'importe où dans le monde quoi c'est un
endroit où on est bien où on a la paix
le calme
justement avec des gens qui vous aiment
bien et
[Musique]
comme si le temps s'était arrêté passe
rien il faut des semaines que pour que
le fait de par exemple si vous décidez
de planter des rosiers ça a l'air d'une
entreprise gigantesque alors qu'il
suffit d'aller les acheter
cinq minutes ça prend trois semaines
comment sud
et la vie
[Musique]
hélas
je nourris
tous
[Musique]
j'adore les enfants j'adore les chiens
jeu d'origine j'aime ou j'aime les gens
d'ailleurs en venir
madame entendre avec lui mais je les
aime votre fils est important très
important surtout en a eu beaucoup de
chance ou un petit garçon très très gai
il est vraiment très très bas qui fut il
aime la musique bruits régis très très
bien ils attendent la musique il papa
on dirait
/
le temps de
et la vie
non
[Musique]
pour ma part à son atelier musiciens
tout en avoir et là vous enregistrer
tous façonnés je cherche des trucs je
fais des maquettes et à la limite
j'enregistre aussi mon ami patrick qui
connaît la technique parce que pour moi
c'est vraiment du chinois
comment ça se passe la confection d'un
disque nous a pour sa part dû d'abord je
commence par avoir pour faire de méli
mélo ding par les harmonies et des
mélodies la musique d'une chanson
après quoi en général c'est le texte
mais s'est longtemps après et ça tombe
mal de temps et puis c'est la recherche
des musiciens pour l'enregistrer choisir
quel genre musiciens parce que les
musiciens peuvent être très différents
les anglais les américains par exemple
sont vraiment complètement différents et
tous filé une totale indifférence
chemmakh américain gm musicien anglais
j'ai français aussi à faut pas se
tromper on se trompe facilement et pose
de problème
puis après une fois contre les musiciens
et bien
on répète avec eux parce que je passe
pratiquement jamais par l'intermédiaire
d'un arrangeur qui m'a choisi mes
musiciens écrit tous les arrangements
je travaille avec des gens m'apportent
tous ensemble dessiner en général
[Musique]
je pense qu'un peintre envie de faire
une exposition pour présenter un tableau
personnellement j'aimerais bien écrire
un roman que des nouvelles un 45 tours
c'est un peu comme des nouvelles ou un
tableau isolé un 33 tours c'est un peu
comme un film disons auquel il peut se
passer des tas de choses
la musique c'est un univers la trois
dimensions c'est vraiment illimité avec
une demi heure aux 48 de musique peut
avoir sur un 33 tours vraiment faire
rentrer quelqu'un dans un univers la
musique que vous écrivez elle pardo
d'une guitare d'un piano autres twitter
d'une guitare et quelquefois d'un piano
est plutôt de la guitare ce que je suis
médiocre pianiste c'est une musique que
vous recherchez où elle arrive tout seul
non je cherche je cours après ça c'est
difficile de passer par le côté je me
promène dans vos jardins il ya un air
car un envoyé du lourd tout de suite et
pas du tout ça commence par les
harmonies j'étais musicien de jazz
pendant longtemps et bassiste à sa main
ça m'a permis d'apprendre à décomposer
les accords vision parce que la base
c'est ça que ça fait en réalité et
comment les harmonies c'est très
importante la suite suite harmonique
l'important c'est là dessus que que
n'importe quelle mélodie peut venir
pourra toujours une bonne mélodie sur
une bonne suite d'armani
[Musique]